واضح ان مشهد ارباك ما زال مسيطرا على
المشهد في اسرائيل الى اي مدى يعمل الان
نتنياهو على خلط
الاوراق بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
ولضيفك الكريم ولجمهور المشاهدين حقيقه
اكتبس اقتبس ما قالوا يهود
اعاريات لال في الوضع الحالي فقال بان
اسرائيل هي مملكه من الفوضى وهذا التعبير
ربما هو الادق نشهد حاله الفوضى والتخبط
الشديده جدا في كل المستويات المجتمع في
حاله فوضى اللاجئين من جهه النازحين من
الشمال والجنوب من جهه عدم الثقه في
الحكومه ارتفاع نسب تعاطي ال الادويه
المهدئه في اسرائيل
30% الامراض النفسيه وتعاطي الكحول زاد
بشكل كبير جدا الوضع الاقتصادي متدهور
نتنياهو ومجلس حربه ليس على وفاق يعني
اليوم عندما يخرج وز رئيس وزراء دوله في
حاله حرب ولا يكون معه اعضاء الكابينت
رئيس ائتلاف المعارضه وقائد القوات او
وزير الدفاع هذا يعتبر كارثه وعندما يسال
عن هذا الموضوع يعني يكون الجواب هو
التجاهل الك الكامل وبالتالي هذه هي صوره
اسرائيل الان تخبط في المشهد السياسي تخبط
في المشهد العسكري تخبط في المشهد
الاقتصادي حتى هناك خلافات شديده على
الميزانيه احزاب اليمين واليمين الديني
تصر على تلقي المخصصات الائتلافيه في ظل
عجز هائل تعاني منه الميزانيه الاسرائيليه
وصل الى ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه بدات تاخذ
اموال من صناديق التقاعد عدم وضوح في
التعامل مع الحلفاء او الحليف الاستراتيجي
وهو الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الجيش لا ي ي لماذا يقاتل لا
يوجد هدف سياسي الجيش الان يقاتل لاجل
القتال
ومايسترو الفوضى ومايسترو هذه الاوركسترا
الهائله من الفوضى هو بنيامين نتنياهو في
نظر الشارع الاسرائيلي سيد اياد مشهد
التخبط السياسي هذا في اسرائيل برايك كيف
سينعكس على مجريات الامور في
غزه المشهد المرتبك الذي ظهر به نتنياهو
اليوم هو يعكس حاله من الانقسام والخلافات
الداخليه التي اصبحت ليست سريه وتحدث عنها
نتنياهو اليوم بشكل واضح بتقدير انعكاسها
على الحرب على غزه هي ترتبط بانه في حال
اتساع الفجوه
بين مجلس الحرب والكبينه واعضاء الحكومه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق في
التعامل مع استمرار هذه الحرب سينعكس
باتجاه امكانيه وقفها او امكانيه يه
الذهاب الى على الاقل تغيير السياسات
الموجوده خاصه فيما يتعلق بالانتقال ما
يسمونه المرحله الثالثه واستمرا واستمرار
العمل نحو وقف هذه الحرب والذهاب الى
صفقه لاطلاق سراح الاسرى من الاسرى من غزه
وخاصه انه جزء من الخلافات الموجوده حاليا
هي تتركز بشكل اساسي على اصوات تعلو كثيرا
داخل كافه مكونات المجتمع الاسرائيلي سواء
على المستوى المجتمع او على المستوى
السياسي تطالب بالذهاب الى صفقه حالا ووقف
هذه الحرب بما فيها رؤساء وزراء سابقون
و ونائب رئيس الاركان السابق وقاده في
الجيش الاسرائيلي السابقين العامل الثاني
ايضا هي ان هذه الخلافات تنعكس بشكل مباشر
على الجيش الاسرائيلي و وما سرب عن الجيش
الاسرائيلي خلال يومين الماضيين بان هناك
مصادر عسكريه كبيره تحدثت ان ان القياده
السياسيه لم تستثمر ما قالوا انه اهداف
عسكريه تم تحقيقها خلال الفتره الماضيه
وانه الخلافات السياسيه ستنعكس سلبا على
اداء الجيش الاسرائيلي وامكانيه ان ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاول ان ينهي الحرب على
غزه باي شكل من الاشكال لانه الجميع يعرف
ان استمرار هذه الحرب خاصه الاسابيع
الاخيره هي بناء على توجه نتنياهو السياسي
اكثر من انها حاجه عسكريه لانه الجيش
يعتبر انه عمليا لم يعد لديه اي اهداف
قادر على تح حقيقه وانه يتكبد خسائر كبيره
بشكل بشكل يومي وتتصاعد وهذا امر بالنسبه
للجيش الاسرائيلي امر خطير يستحق التوقف
وقد يكون عامل ضغط على الجيش الاسرائيلي
استمرار هذه الخلافات